we are going to go over how to use
c-test in today's video this probably
comes right after the installing your
software episode 1 or part 1 of 2 of
that i think it's actually episode 6. i
could be wrong i have to look yes uh
episode six was correct it would be it
probably should go here if we're
following the loose structure of cmake's
actual tutorial but it doesn't
necessarily matter let's go over how to
use c-test this is going to be a
two-parter first part is going to be
about c test and running test and
testing your code the second part i
think goes hand-in-hand with this is the
dashboard you can use that is optional
to review your tests and do nightly
tests and kind of a software development
life cycle type thing but uh the first
part is kind of the the crux of it's
what actually tests your code and that
sort of thing so let's get into it now
the classic way to use cmake is through
the terminal but a lot of ides i've
integrated it into them so there's a lot
of different ways i could show you how
to do this
now it's critical that that makes sense
because the way i'm doing it might be a
little different but on the underlying
way is the same your editor or ide or
whatever is still running commands
behind the scenes with cmake usually
based off of config files or something
so i'm just going to show it a couple
different ways uh real quick let's just
start with the terminal so here we have
windows powershell but also i do have
linux so uh we can launch into wsl which
is essentially linux it's not exactly
obviously but it's based off of uh this
ubuntu it might be updated i haven't
updated this too recently but basically
i am in linux at this point so you can
use things like ls take a look around
and you can see i am on my i'm on my c
drive all right i don't necessarily want
to be on my cdr so we can go back a
couple directories to our e drive let's
do that now let us just go to e no let's
just go back a directory yeah okay first
command should have worked i just typed
something wrong i guess so here's our e
drive and i have a source file here
that has a bunch of source all right so
from here we could start a new project
from command line like you would do in
linux in a lot of cases and uh if you're
using an ide this is just all done for
you basically when you hit new project
and all that so we will i'll do that and
after this but
you know critical programming knowledge
you should probably know let's zoom this
in a little all right well let's just
make a new directory called cma or i
don't remember what to call this anymore
maybe i should just clone the old one
that i was building on github for a
while do i have that cloned no i don't
so we could go clone that first let's
make sure we have game by just typing it
yeah we do we have it ready to go and
let's make sure we have cma and we do
it's ready to go the reason i'm checking
here in case you don't know it's because
i am now in wsl which is basically its
own environment it is not my windows
environment it is a linux environment so
it has its own installs of things okay
i've managed to find it this is the repo
now this hasn't been updated for two
years i remember in the early episodes i
cheekily named it our lord and savior
for no particular reason and i guess
it's kind of a double-edged sword
because i guess it peaked some interest
but also it's like it's kind of a
controversial thing to say for some
reason um but that's the name of the
repo so it is what it is we're going to
just get clone and then i got that
copied already actually i'm going to
make sure i do and uh just go to code
copy okay and we just want to paste it
here which apparently a right click does
in this power shell terminal
so there we go let's go ahead that
and i have an e let's add it could not
okay
okay i think i need to add this some
key to it all right let me say i'll get
this figured out
i just got really distracted looking at
a bunch of my old repos and realized i
had pull requests that i never realized
i had some projects so i guess i gotta
address those at some point all right so
a slight derailment and uh this probably
won't happen to you but uh
to add my ssh key i have to uh have a
pen i don't know what this is talking
about i have no authenticator for this
but i tried all the obvious stuff that i
could have guessed like but uh all right
so we're just gonna have to clone it
without this stuff it's a public repo so
it's not a big deal we just have to
clone it using
https rather than ssh so yeah all right
so let's just do that let's go get loan
put it in there and no issues as
expected okay so now we can cd into it
and take a look at what we're working
with oh man this file this stuff is so
old um so
we can just open this with any editor we
could of course use something like them
do i have them installed i do okay but
that's a little risky in my opinion
because the chance of a lock up on your
terminal is uh is never fun so we're
going to use visual studio code and
we'll just type code and dot and that
should do it
apparently it has an update there's some
kind of server integration thing it
needs to do because this terminal of
course is basically linux trust all the
authors of source uh probably not did i
open source no i opened okay
yeah this is fine so there's this little
adder library that has its own cmake
okay yep that's old school external glfw
is even anything in here no okay and we
have cmake here this is the top level
one and this is probably where we're
going to do the test adding but i just
want to go over this old file because
it's been so long and i honestly don't
fully remember without taking a look so
let's zoom in and uh see what we got
here that's fine it's fine fine package
okay do we actually launch glue is there
a glue thing going on here uh let's
check out the main yeah okay so i was
doing some opengl thing and that's fine
do we use any glue here let's take a
look yeah we are using glue okay oh
we're using that instead of glad i
believe here okay well it doesn't
necessarily matter we just need to pick
a test essentially this main right here
is a test but you know
the problem with this piece of software
is it has no direction it doesn't really
have a thing that it does other than
it's just an example so we could in
theory do whatever we want but
essentially this main is a test file so
it probably is best that we move it into
the tester area so what we're going to
do is we're going to make a new folder
and you can do this however you want i
guess you know if you're in visual
studio you can click this new folder
button but if you want to stick to the
terminal you can just go make dir tests
and change directory to tests and we can
move that whole file let's go back
directory main well hold on first let's
make another folder let's make a test
called uh i hate design decisions have
ever told you guys that when i'm trying
to give examples i hate having to come
up with designs it feels like it derails
everything for me let's just make one
called graphics all right and we'll go
into graphics and ultimately we just
want to move that other main all the way
back here into graphics and that should
take care of it and now let's create
another file see make this txt is it
list my tune yeah okay i couldn't
remember if it was plural or not okay
but it's fine so now we have this folder
called tests and i'm just tabbing in
between the terminal and that i know you
can't really see it so just trying to
make it not confusing but maybe if i put
my taskbar up here that'll help some
people
but also i need to close a lot of this
stuff there we go much better so now we
have these tests and its graphics so uh
test has a cmake and a main oh test
slash graphics
the way visual studio works with these
folders is if you have an empty folder
no other stuff it just you know
automatically goes to it so let's
actually make another folder here and
call it uh just math that'll be fine and
then we can make i'm just going to do
the new file this way because it's
faster another c make this dot txt and
this will all make sense more shortly
and we're going to make under this math
one another main because essentially
each one of these tests are their own
little executable that does some sort of
thing
that's uh generally how it goes because
you know you got to have an executable
somewhere all right so the graphics one
we already moved all this file into here
let's see what it does in this this main
it returns an end uh let's just see what
it returns here to return zero do we
have anywhere else in here we'll return
something else yeah there's some return
negative one uh type stuff yeah okay so
we can just basically see if this
returns a zero and a one when we run
this main what we're going to end up
doing um but we're going to kind of
layer these tests a little bit all right
so we want a cmake file and tests as
well because every directory needs one
if it's going to command stuck very
directory driven
setup of a project it's just the way
cmake is and that's if you like
directory based stuff it's kind of the
way to go you know
all right so in this top level one well
we need to call it somewhere we have our
old cmake list.text here now uh
most of the stuff is just fine we can
just leave it we got the old cpac stuff
sure all right that's fine but uh there
are
some things we're gonna have to correct
and we'll just do that as we go it's not
it's not too big of a deal and the
reality is also so if we're running this
on this terminal uh that's wsl and
windows the graphics stuff isn't gonna
work we're gonna expect it to fail quite
frankly uh so that just to let you know
but when you run it on linux or whatever
something that actually has a proper uh
call to the graphics api it should work
fine
and there might be some way to make this
do that but i don't expect it to work uh
out of the whatever
and if you do get it to work it's going
to be kind of hacky anyway in my
experience because i've done that before
a long time ago for a school project but
enough about me let's continue so
basically all we want to do in this top
level one is just add directory so we
can do that kind of anywhere we want i
guess it kind of makes sense to do it
after you've checked that this is all
going to work but there's some sort of
odd things here now like this ad sub
directory external jlfw right this i
believe is a sub module and if you want
the sub modules you have to clone with
recursive which i did not do
obviously here when i did the clone i
just did uh what did i do git clone and
so i need a dash dash recursive on here
but that's okay if you fail to get it
there's a command you can run to go
ahead and grab all the sub modules so
i'm going to do that and i'm realizing
that i'm kind of scattering around a bit
but i'm also walking through updating
this old project as is that way we have
a greater understanding of the scope of
how to work this into projects while
also learning c-test all right it should
just be get sub-module in it now you
know as i was looking at the stuff i
realized you know i think we can just
pop up the terminal nbs code here with
terminal new terminal yeah and we're on
our mount uh over here where we launched
it which is interesting because now we
are
essentially running two of these wsl
terminals now i wonder what happens if i
close this for science is it going to
crash wsl over here that actually gives
us an idea of how it's coded whether
it's using like a shared pointer setup
or what but um
all right let's do it's fine it's fine
so cool all right wsl still running so
from this point forward we're just gonna
use the terminal right here um rather
than that uh windows one just just
because but it's essentially the same
thing going on now i said whether it's
using a shared pointer but that's
actually probably invalid it's just the
way it does things is it like a shared
thing or is i was wondering if that
terminal was like master runningness but
whatever all right we just want to go
ahead and grab that sub module so i
think we just do
get sub module init okay registered path
but it didn't actually download anything
yet all right so let's see what have we
got to do here okay then let's get sub
module update and there we go and
that'll go ahead and grab jlfw and its
latest form so that's kind of cool and
that is actually required in our cmake
here i think when we run cmake it might
even do that for us automatically uh
because of this here and as you can see
it does basically what we did there uh
sub mod execute process get sub module
update or init recursive i guess that's
what all we could have typed rather than
init than update uh we could have just
done the submit recursive thing which
you probably actually want to do because
if your sub modules have submodules you
got to do that recursive thing so sort
of interesting let's just do that let's
go in and recursive and see if it does
anything like it just failed
oh we got to go update it's sub module
update recursive okay there we go but uh
no changes
so we just want to work out these tests
anyway i just want to make sure that was
going in retrospect that was all kind of
a waste of time because this was going
to do it anyway
i forgot about that so what we want to
do is just add this directory called
test and once we add this directory it's
going to basically look for the cmake
list and the cmake is going to do stuff
so another what we want to do here is
well this test file if you're adding
this then you want test in basically so
we're going to enable testing first of
all enable test i think that's how you
do it i think and then we're going to do
add subdirectory or add subdirectory is
what i meant and we're going to do one
for graphics which basically means it's
going to look for a c make list in that
file which there is one and of course
this one is just going to go add
executable and we need a name for the
executable we'll call it uh graphics
underscore test sure and it needs all
its parameter stuff there we go and this
is the one that actually needs glfw
so we won't want to do add or target
link libraries and uh whatever we call
glfw i think just deal w well oh yeah we
need the project name or the executable
name graphics test and then we just call
it grfw let's take a look so if we go
back to our root level one so really we
should probably be doing all this
library stuff in this test maybe this is
honestly kind of a weird example at this
point because of how it's set up oh yeah
this dot in i almost forgot about this
too so we could even add put defines in
here for stuff about testing like uh
yeah we'll get to that later but i'll
just add subdirectory yes we already do
that
let's do a find oh okay so that's all we
should need to do there
library search library stuff there we go
we got this target link libraries
there's no longer a target in this main
top level one so the project name is
still the same that's fine if use adder
add subdirectory for adder that's
perfectly fine we don't need to mess
with that add executable project name
now this is kind of where it uh gets
awkward working in this configure file
all right well this executable
ultimately is just gone it's it's the
one that's now here since we moved this
main we probably want this in there yeah
actually we want all of this in here yep
you know this whole project name is
going away because there's going to be
multiple executables we don't want to
all name the project name
all right so i just cut all that stuff
and uh we're just gonna put it all right
here anywhere it says project name we
need to change that to graphics test
and it's it is gonna know about this uh
extra lives and stuff but it doesn't
really i don't think it even uses it
does its check do we have adder yeah we
do include it but do we use it at all
yeah we have some little c out that says
we are but honestly this is a total sub
point so what we actually want to do is
put this in its own main under mat and
just do that sort of thing let's just uh
assume adder is well we can assume it's
optional with this config
but and there it is
here so this is just gonna pipe it to
the c plus plus code basically this
config and uh yeah that way the user
when they call cmake can decide if they
want to use adder it's going to default
to on right so maybe this would be this
would turn into something like well use
adder is fine but right now i think
we're going to go test adder on and
we'll do this for another one too s
graphics s launch ngl
and we'll default that one go on so you
can change these if you pass and dash c
and uh in this option i think it's dash
c but uh we'll play around with that a
little later and everything that says
use adder we want to change to so we'll
need to do that here we'll need to do
that here and we'll also need to make
another one of these and call it test
graphics right that's what we called it
test graphics yeah so then if these are
on that's when we want to do all this
adding of sub directories and now this
adder library if we're not using it
doesn't need to be built but how do we
know if we're using it well currently
the only thing that uses it is this test
so we could push all of this config
stuff into these tests but i don't
really like that idea because in theory
this isn't a piece of software to just
run test theory it actually does the
stuff like it does graphics or does math
so it always wants those and uh whether
you're running the tests or not is
what's optional whether you have the
libraries well they're just part of the
project i hope that makes sense but
essentially this isn't a real project is
the point it's just some config test all
right let's uh let's continue targets
project name yeah this install isn't
going to work anymore because we won't
have a project name we're going to have
tests and yeah i guess we want to check
if we're using those you know let's just
uh let's put in more options here let's
keep that use adder option in here use
nope there we go yes there we go this
one will be test so we'll have use and
test we'll have just more options so
let's put this back in here and that way
we can have access to these in our c
plus plus code if we in case we want
them because there might be relevant
scenarios or we might want to check it
or change it in these lower cmake files
too all right add subdirectory graphics
add subdirectory map yeah i guess we
would we would check them here at this
point um to see if we want to test or
not because ultimately for testing we
want to add that sub directory if so we
would just put an if here basically and
we could put if test data or test
graphics and the subdirectory i think we
could kind of do an end if just the way
this is let's see make there we go so i
think that's correct and then we can go
in here and we could even be a little
more specific more ifs which is somewhat
redundant at this point but uh if tests
graphics and we can do a little end if
here and then we can do this one for the
math yeah best math and we're going to
put an and here and use adder because uh
you can't test the math if we're not
using it right
so it would actually fail to compile in
theory if we're not even using the adder
but we're trying to test the math and
there we go and that'll just call these
to do their thing alrighty so this one
we need to pass in something we'll get
to that here in a second when we do add
tests we still haven't done ad test my
goodness this is a very convoluted
example i almost feel bad all right but
basically all we want to do is add
executable on this map and call it uh
math test or something and then we want
to target
link libraries uh project source dir i
believe
oh we need to target here of course
which is manifest okay and that should
take care of that so we have those
executables added now we just need to
actually add the tests which we do in
this top level one uh let's just do it
right here add test and you basically do
its name and all that well you basically
uh follow this so you give it a name a
command and uh config working directory
and that's about it so let's go ahead
and do that and test you gotta put name
here and we'll call it uh test1 and now
yeah just one sure now the commands
graphics test and then next we need the
arguments for this command now the
arguments get passed into uh this hard c
r v thing uh we'll address this adder
one later it'll need it there now also
another thing is you're probably not
gonna get a console out on running these
tests you're just gonna get a pass fail
well we'll see it might be different
here it depends on your framework but
sometimes this console out doesn't do
anything for tests because it's not how
you're supposed to use them basically
your tests are supposed to just pass
fail based on whatever it's doing all
right well let's look at this test so
graphics test do we want to give it any
commands that's what i was trying to get
to here and ultimately it looks like
uh
it spits out whatever you say or
whatever the name of this program is so
it's probably just going to call it like
uh graphics test yeah this will say
graphics test version and then it'll say
oh lost major version which those are in
the config so that's or they're right
here they're in this version they're
piped into your source files with this
config basically
but uh that's kind of weird at this
point honestly well i'm just gonna leave
it i'll change this version to 1.1 but
uh it's very awkward for these tests we
don't really want to do this honestly um
so it'd probably be better to check for
actual arguments um
yeah forget the arguments we're not
going to pipe in anything for this one
but you can and then you have to process
ops
and do whatever you know you're supposed
to do with those options but i don't
want to get into that too much so we're
just gonna kind of ignore these for now
but that is essentially what this spot
would be uh it'd be the ops or the you
know commands to pass that so we're just
going to skip that all right another
thing people usually do is rather than
have all these main.cpps in your test
folders as they name these tester so
that needs to reflect in the cmake of
course too and it can we can go down the
line like that and we'll just update
those so now at this point we should be
able to run cmake and if we're testing
we will be adding all this test stuff
and adding the directories for it which
will uh go to this file enable testing
and then test some graphics or whatever
we want via these add subdirectory and
then add test all right so this one
should be good to go although we do need
to specify uh the results or what we're
expecting out of this but ultimately
we're gonna expect to return zero if
everything's fine and return something
else if there's an error so we're not
going to get into that too much mainly
we want to set the working directory
here working directly now this command
and name you should put these in
parentheses
and i could have said this earlier but
you know just kind of realized and then
uh let's put in put in the r1 doesn't do
anything it's just going to be those
characters working directory now we want
to set this uh to the macro cma current
binary
apparently we don't have that set so
we'll just have to take a look at what's
going on there uh yeah it should be fine
all right so we just want to do that for
both of these let's add a test down here
from the math one and of course its name
is going to be
math test now uh this command isn't
exactly going to work because it needs
to know how to get to these tests and
essentially we need to go down another
directory kind of like uh this would be
under mat and this one would be under uh
let's see graphics now we wouldn't have
to do that if we added these tests right
here somewhere in this directory so it
might actually be better to do it rather
than the top level one is to uh just add
the subdirectories here and then these
tests put the actual tests in there and
then we don't have to worry about
pathing down to that folder so yeah
that's actually going to be better so
we'll just do that in math as well and
we can get rid of this and that should
take care of it let's give it a run now
to give it a run we basically just go
back to our terminal and from our top
directory of the project type into cmake
we'll say the source is the current
directory and we will say that
the output
um
oh no it's dash b capital b build we can
say that that is see if i can make this
any bigger that's all that's the best i
can do i think before it gets too
jumbled all right and we want this to
just go to well
let's just go to a build folder that's
fine now it might complain that the
build folder is not there nope it
created it for us that's nice and it's
doing its thing so we can see here that
it did have an error it's missing the
glue libraries so we required that for
the tests um we could either turn that
off or we could see about installing the
glue library so let's just do aft search
glue because they should be here
uh in this ubuntu install and here we
are we have glue it's probably going to
be live glue dev yeah probably just live
glue dev so we'll do apt install live
blue dev and it looks like it's locked
so we got to do sudo and it wants the
password now i think my password this
guessing no maybe it's this there we go
okay obviously i'm not going to tell you
guys what my password is but you get the
point here now it failed a bunch of
stuff this is probably because it's
really outdated so what we need to do
here is sudo apt update and then we need
to probably do an upgrade because it's
probably got a bunch of old it's
probably pointing to a bunch of old
stuff that's no longer there so we can
go apt list sure let's see what's
upgradeable bunch of stuff so pseudo app
upgrade this is going to take a little
while not too long i guess but after
this we should be able to install live
glue so you know this is just an an
artifact i'll say artifact i don't
necessarily mean that of the way we used
to be doing this project with glue
required i think that was from episode 8
or 9 but ultimately there are other ways
to do it like if we could find the glue
source up on github we could make that
another external thing and sub module it
in with that same sub module code so
it's kind of just another example of
another way to do things
so you know a lot of capabilities you
don't have to use them all just trying
to find ways to fill this time while the
progress bar at the bottom is going but
i think it's important to realize that
there's just quite a few different ways
of doing those different things so we
could literally stick to only submodulin
and say we're not doing them any other
way if we wanted or we could say we're
only going to do the ones from
our linux have to get and no other way
or we're only going to add them in
manually uh like so and we're not gonna
use uh anything else that way it's all
just a fully included project you don't
have to worry about getting other stuff
there's just a lot of ways to do that
but it looks like this is all updated so
let's go ahead and install live blue now
and there we go very good so we should
be able to rerun our cmake command uh
there it is and it shouldn't have any
trouble finding it this time looks like
it didn't it's fine
but it now has a problem well
we basically have some old projects i
think found glue but the install target
does not exist okay yeah we took that
target away so let's find let's go to
this top level cmake oh yeah it's this
right here this this install targets is
not going to work anymore
we could take this and put it in these
tests so it could install these tests
which is a little awkward but whatever
and we'll just call this graphic that's
destination bin yeah sure so you can
just manually run graphics tests
basically from that install uh we'll do
the same thing we have markets this
would be graphics test and we could
macro this of course to not have to keep
retyping graphics tests um you know but
it's fine and we just do the same thing
here install math test get that all
fixed up so it'll just exist in the bin
yeah i think we're good all right let's
go ahead and run the command again see
if that sorts out that error we might
have to regenerate at some point here
too so we might have to do a a clean and
rebuild oh let's see what's it complain
test adder or test graphics arguments
specified let's see here
line 29 so let's go to line 29 it
doesn't like something about the way
i've done this i think maybe this is
this or not legal i gotta do it like
that i forget honestly cmake has some
different syntax uh so i'm just gonna do
some quick research by going to google
and typing in cmake and or so here's the
documentation on it we can take a look
we can see if there's an or uh no and oh
it's capitalized okay so and or yeah
they're all here all the conditional
syntax if you need it you can go find it
it's so secret but i was i had a
lowercase ore and it looks like that
doesn't work so we'll capitalize that i
think somewhere i had a
lowercase and maybe so i'm going to take
a quick look see if i can uh find that
real quick uh maybe it was here right
here so that'll probably throw an error
too so we'll go ahead and get that fixed
all right and let's go ahead and run
that again now it's having a problem
with external glfw which is not a
directory um so why would it say that
right line 26 let's take a look at line
26 uh that's not here so we must be
talking about uh this one under graphics
let's go here uh yeah subdirectory we
now have to go back a couple directories
uh but we could also go uh take it from
the cmake source dir see my current
source during the way let's see is that
right because i think that's the root
level yeah i think that's root in this
case i believe we need to trail and
slash that which is a little different
from a lot of windows stuff all right so
let's run that again see if that clears
up that error from line 26 all right we
got another one on line 26
uh current source dir is the directory
of the cmake so that's not right so we
would want like
project sourced or maybe is there is
that a thing i don't know there's some
root directory command i don't remember
what it is but we're just going to rely
on going back to directories because
we're in this graphics folder and then
we go back one to test back another one
to the root and then we can go into
external so this should work but there
probably is a macro that would fit there
i just can't think of it and i don't
care anymore at this point let's just go
all right now we got another error to
work out add subdirectory not given a
binary directory but given the source
directory not given a binary directory
okay so we're doing something weird here
i guess we go project source dir instead
yeah that's probably just i don't know
if we're supposed to be adding
subdirectory
when the subdirectory is at a higher
level because this right here is going
to clone it into the test i believe
working directory currency make source
dir which would be wherever this one is
so it'd be
yeah yeah i guess this sub module thing
doesn't really work um from this level
so let's just take this and put this all
on the top left alright so to do that we
just go to the top level one and uh
we'll put it somewhere up here after
find glue i guess yeah download yeah so
this will essentially
get you off w from github right that's
all it does and then uh there we go all
right so that should be better we might
have to just delete some of this let's
just delete this build folder and uh we
should be good from there because that's
going to reset
everything sometimes you need i don't
know if we need to do that necessarily
but a lot of times you want to do that
if you had some pretty major changes and
you're not sure essentially not going to
hurt anything
r and r header is not fine found so
configuring glfw didn't work
it looks like they require a library
that we don't have so let's go ahead and
just go app search live x r and r and
there is a couple of those looks like we
need to install live r and r
dev and we need to use sudo okay now
let's run our cmake again and looks like
we're missing another
development environment let's just guess
that it's called exactly that and let's
try again so these are just requirements
to compile glfw because we are building
glfw from the source um and just finding
out that we're missing a lot of
requirements to do that and thankfully
linux makes it easy to get them and if
they're common packages but uh yeah you
probably won't have that trouble looks
like we're going to keep doing this for
a while until we get them all it's kind
of unprecedented and not necessarily
part of the tutorial but maybe you'll
appreciate seeing it and you'll learn
something so let's keep going just keep
trying the same thing until we get them
all build files have been written okay
it is now successful so we can now run
our tests so how do you run your tests
well let's see if i can get this right
on the first try now of course naturally
you can change directory into the build
directory see what's in there and we
should see all our stuff there's our
adder library there's external there's
tests we are interested in tests you can
just go to that directory with change
directory and see the tests there's
graphics uh i don't see the adder one or
the math one wonder why not so i must
have missed something here if test math
and use that are okay add subdirectory
math we add so directory math do we have
everything here i think so target link
like is this successful is it let's see
both of these these all should be true
right on on and on now did we actually
add the subdirectory or all this stuff
tests yes yeah it looks fine okay but
for some reason it didn't actually build
the math one and i'm not entirely sure
why but uh yeah so we should still be
able to go change directory into
graphics and uh basically run make here
to build it now this build since it
requires jlw is going to fully build it
and we have some errors with the adder
and how its path
but uh let's see what are we missing
let's go back directory here there's a
make file on
the test subfolder let's try that one
same thing all right let's go back
another directory to build there's a
make file here let's run that all right
so all of them fail they're basically
failing on this can't find the adder.h
and uh it looks like that is from the
graphics tester so we have to see uh
what's going on here essentially we
don't use it here we haven't included it
anywhere so we don't actually need this
here at all so that should be all it is
and now we want to go back to the root
directory and just run that cmake
command again alright now rather than
pathing down there we can just type make
and then dash capital c and then go to
the directory which is built and it'll
run the make file in there it looks like
it's doing its thing it seemed to be
successful i'm going to read through
this it does say warning clock skew
detected your build may be incomplete
okay so whatever there's there's some
kind of time discrepancy i don't know
why it's doing that but we should have
everything so now
uh we should be able to run this tester
so i believe we can do this with
okay we got to go to the binary
directory so build that's graphics and
we'll see it there so we can now go c
test
dash capital n i think yeah there we go
seem to do it test one test one total
test is one okay so i think dash n is
just just list them all let's go from
this top level and see what it does same
thing okay i'm not it's not clear to me
whether that ran the test or not um but
let's just run graphics test it does not
launch it just instantly fails uh we can
see what it returns i guess with like uh
with a call to it somehow it's at least
doing the c out so we know it's running
but it's probably returning negative one
right away when it's failing on uh
probably this stuff like this init
window i think it's gonna fail because
uh well it's not necessarily attached to
the os's windowing system
through this wsl terminal pretty sure
that's what's going on uh but it's hard
to tell
it could be just flying through and
doing nothing to all right it would
probably help if we um name this test
something better than graphics test or
better than test one like graphics tests
okay in uh this caps case and we can do
the same thing here oh they're both the
same name that was actually probably why
they're not both building
it might have been the source of several
problems there so let's go back to our
root directory here and rebuild graphics
let's redo the cmake thing there it is
now they both have different names so
expecting somewhat of a different update
or different results here let's run make
and now it looks like it built some
stuff it still didn't build the second
set of tests the math tests
all right
it's probably not linking we needed to
link don't we extra includes what was
that it's from this list.append okay so
yeah that's something to think about as
well we did a link libraries to this
include what that shouldn't work all
right so it's this one this is what we
actually need over here
don't need glue this one doesn't need
these external okay
so this would be a little better
alright link live we need target link
libraries here too that looks fine okay
i'm honestly surprised it wasn't
throwing errors from all this stuff
certainly wasn't building the math test
though let's see if it built them now no
just graphics in here oh it's test adder
that's why it's not adding test math is
not a thing so i guess it evaluates to
zero i don't know i'm surprised didn't
throw an error there because i think do
we have test math defined anywhere yes
no we don't um i don't understand why it
wouldn't show throw an error there
honestly but that's fine we'll just
remake this thing cmake command one more
time at the root level
should get some different results this
time for sure and now let's run the make
file and we get some version errors in
the math tester okay whatever um let's
just delete we don't need these oh we
didn't we don't have anything included
so of course it's not gonna know where
anything is
so we would need to include guess all
these extra no
i think it's this configure file or the
so lost config let's see if we can
include that here nope doesn't know
where it is okay well it doesn't matter
we don't actually need that what we
actually want here is the adder if
anything and then we just want to add
whatever we pass in and expect that as
the result
just executable there's the test uh
let's pass in one and four and we'll
just go
and uh return that return part b well
the count has to be three it's less than
three then let's return negative one
otherwise we'll return what does this
function add rv
zero is the name of the project so this
one will be those other parameters we
should get a five it should be two all
right well let's see if that works
it doesn't know where adder is okay so
we are adding it at some point right
link directories include directories a
lot this should
it's not working as expected um or i'm
just a little lost i'm debating do we
need to install it somewhere see we add
the adder i think we need to do the
install so that we get these libraries
okay we do have this install looks like
it goes to live and include we have
those in our build no so where are they
getting installed i guess nowhere right
now
because i get you know we have to
actually run the install which would be
like uh
cma stall and it has an error process
and it's processing the file okay now
this might have an error processing it
because this probably looks for our uh
drive but we're just gonna have to
pre-fix it with something like uh i
don't know i guess mount e
source
yeah i guess we'll just use this
directory itself and then build and then
where we'll go from there i guess we'll
go make an install folder let's see if
that works no all right i don't know if
the install is going to work on here
anyway well it did at least build the
math test it just doesn't see the adder
file or tried to build it rather
so we could try a different map a few
different methods and just see what
happens but we could also just
it's just that if it's installed this
this isn't going to be correct so we
gotta we gotta think about that a little
bit so that should work cannot convert
character to flow okay so i guess
converting these to floats is a thing
that i hadn't really thought about um i
guess we could just uh say we don't care
what it is just convert it to a ant or a
float but they're characters yeah these
come in as little characters so we'd
have to string stream them in or
something like that now some quick
google searches reveal that there's some
easy ways to do this but you know
because it's kind of a common problem uh
it looks like you can go atof of the rv
so uh let's just see if this works i've
never used this command before but hey
let's just let's just hit the button and
see what happens atof is uh what
that's from the c standard live so we'll
have to include that and now it runs so
now we can run our little math test but
let's just go c test dash in and see
what we got text one if we go back or
directory what does it do let's let's
see text two okay so there's both the
tests
and we go
let's see i think we can do wrong all
right so we gotta do c test dash vv to
run them all so you do see test dash in
to see what you're working with and then
dash or dash n see your tests and then
dash capital v twice and there's some
configures and stuff but we're not
messing with those and as you can see
here um
starts the graphics test and it uh times
out and the second test start math test
it also seems to fail very quickly now
ultimately it fails both of these just
say fail because they don't really
actually know what they're looking for i
think they're just looking for a zero
so that's probably the only thing that's
going to be a success in these cases
unless we add some properties to the
test so what we can do is we can just
take this test uh rather than adding
properties yet is we can just take
whatever number this is and assume that
we'll just compare it to like what c
plus plus does with it right so we'll
use that adder or we'll go uh int cpp
add value i don't know just we'll get
you know we'll get a benchmark here
that's what c plus plus does what and
then actually we'll do float here and
then we'll go like another float called
the adder add value which sounds strange
and uh we'll do that uh yeah so this
one's using the add function this one's
just going to use well just the standard
plus you know like so convert that to a
float convert that to a float see what
we get this one same convert them to
flows but also call this add command
from our adder library and now we just
want to return whether these are equal
or not so we can just do a little
comparison like that so if they're equal
we'll get a zero they're not equal we'll
get some kind of failure result we can
make that a little more explicit by
going bull is equal just set it equal to
whatever that resolves to all right and
then we can just return is equal all
right so let's let's try that let's
remake this whole thing make our tests
and then let's run uh our c test again
and they still seem to fail okay i just
realized
that i have not been recording and i
don't know for how long because i was
talking and anyway i went ahead and went
to this math cmake test added a bunch
more tests gave them some different
numbers but they should all essentially
do the same thing and see if they get
this return value correctly and if they
do it'll pass so we can just go back to
our terminal and we're in our test
directory here under build and we can
see them all with the c test dash n
or we can run them all with dash double
capital v and we'll see that all the
math ones will pass the graphics one
will still fail and it gives us a little
result at the end so that's essentially
how you get it locally going here using
subdirectories and add tests and enable
tests and now let's check out a simple
example on windows rather than linux
because this has basically been very
linux central so here we go
so we're going to go ahead and just
launch visual studio here 2022 the
latest edition and i'm just going to do
a new project and it's got some
templates here i'm just going to choose
the cmake project here just for ease of
use it's just going to give us some
starter files and you should know how to
understand these cmake project one sure
i'm just going to leave it that for now
i'm probably going to delete this
afterwards opens a window it went on my
other screen there it is
all right and there's nothing here
solution explorer is blank i think it's
still working yeah there it goes okay it
gives us a little overview pages i'm
going to close this i don't want the
order overview page but you can see it
has our project structure over here we
got an out it does out build but we do
have a top level cmake and some cmake
presets which we're going to kind of
ignore for now uh we're just going to
assume it's it's fine so this
automatically this top level cmake gives
us a version gives us a project name and
it adds a sub directory so let's take a
look at this subdirectory subdirectory
has another cmake which has minimum
version again i guess i should be doing
that in mine too which i haven't been
for all the sub ones but you probably
should add executable this is where it
adds uh dot cp and dot h see what those
are um just a hello world
so if we run this and you can run it uh
so you could uh you know you can open it
and you can run it via your terminal by
going to whatever builds or you can just
go up here to select startup item and
find it on the list here and run that
debug's fine sure so this is just this
example of how to do it with an ide and
there's hello cmake seems to run fine
for a starter project so let's add some
testing here uh let's just go ahead and
make a new folder so we're just gonna go
up here and add a new folder at the root
level and we'll just call this uh we'll
just call it testing so in testing we're
gonna add another file see make list txt
and we'll do the same thing as this one
sort of let me just grab all this uh
paste this in here so we do want to add
executable uh but we need it to be a
test right actually we don't want to add
x cube here let's just add sub directory
so we're going to make more tests uh
let's just make them called math for now
what the heck is this it just auto
corrected something all right so we need
to under testing go ahead and make this
math one folder called matte lowercase
and we're just going to add to this a
new file we'll just call it tester.cpp
we also need a cmake file in here to
configure it the makelist.txt
so in this tester
we just want main and uh rc of course rv
double star this needs to be an end this
needs to be a character and we just want
to test some math so what are we testing
exactly um we have to find out so we
could pass in values and just test that
it returns them that's kind of
too simple though so uh we'll just
return zero for now uh we'll say if rxc
is one return zero and maybe if we pass
in values it'll not if rxc is greater
than one uh return negative one sure or
you know what we could just return i
don't know it's also false so this would
be a failure basically and this would be
a success now it's going to be a 1 by
default because it's going to have one
argument and it's the name of the
program so if we don't pass in anything
it's going to succeed if we pass in
anything at all it's going to fail
that's that's our case it's it's very
simple it's it's really doesn't you know
we just don't have anything to actually
test here this is the point but now when
we go to our cmake we have that
subdirectory but now we want another sub
directory oh i guess we should be using
these quotes and that's this one's
called testing so i had had the testing
let's go ahead and put this in quotes
visual studio i swear
i can't even end my quotes i'm just
literally not allowed okay whatever i
have to delete the second one for that
to work okay so visual studio also
reruns everything automatically so it's
just kind of like did its thing when i
hit save so add the subdirectory but
we're not actually done in this
subdirectory one we also want to be sure
to enable testing otherwise it's not
gonna work so now it should work uh so
what happens once the cmake's done we
should get a new project up here in this
drop down uh on the startup item we
should get one for
this tester we gotta fill out this cmake
um i i guess we do the same thing let's
go let's get our minimum version in here
okay so this is the math level one uh
and we also need to of course add
executable um we'll just call it uh math
test and it takes ester.cpp i don't
really need anything else it's fine and
we need to of course at this point add a
test so we could do that here
and uh you know we can do that here now
you don't necessarily have to do it with
these subfolders you can do it all root
level on this top one uh if you want but
it just it just gets i like organizing
files and folders so we just want to do
an add test here and we'll just call it
uh let's give it a name we need name of
some sort it's called math test one i
guess yes
and this test needs to have a command
i'm gonna call math test and it wants
variables also one's a working directory
which is just going to be cmake binary
directory so yeah that's you know that's
going to be it's working directory all
right it looks like cmake generation is
going
so now that we have this new executable
here we should be able to go up here and
click it and just give it a quick run
looks like it has some syntax errors
these are supposed to be here i need
that and it just builds and runs it
nothing to see here so how do you run
the test well you can go to this test
explorer and you should see them come up
if you hit run all see if it actually
works okay it says build your solution
discover all available tasks or click
run all to build discover and run all
tests um so was there where's the runoff
let's go up to here now this might not
actually work with cmake this little
tool there's yeah i don't think it does
okay so it's possible that we need to
install frameworks for these tests uh it
looks like that might be a thing
but yeah essentially we should be seeing
any tests we have added which it should
at least see this one in this test
explorer so i'm not sure why that's not
happening but i think we can maybe open
up a terminal and see what we can do
here let's go see test bash in uh let's
go into the al slash build let's go to
the six to four debug and now let's try
c test dash in doesn't see it let's go
into testing now let's try c test n okay
and now we see a bunch of tests could
not find executable test so i guess it's
looking for specific files called test
uh what's going on here maybe this name
is no good so maybe we got to do
something like that i'm not 100 sure
what's going on there so we just have to
kind of look around a little bit and
there now it finds it
okay so it was looking for multiple
executables it was looking for
executable math and i was looking for
the executable test then it was probably
going to look for one so yeah having
spaces in there was no good it looks
like you don't want to have spaces in
this name so good to know maybe that's
what i wasn't finding it in the solution
explorer let's hit run all again and see
what happens it's doing something seems
to be running some background tasks not
sure what those are exactly but
we should be able to run them now let's
see if we can run them in the command
line with the dash two capital v's and
it does run them okay and looks like it
passes yep passed which is expected now
if we do another one that we expect to
fail like we could add another test here
math test two and we can just make it
fail by passing in something here uh
because that's that's what's supposed to
happen at least now we have a second
test to work with here and uh we should
be able to see all these up here well
there's our executable so you can see
your executables up here but if you
actually want to run the test looks like
you got to either do that in command
line or get this test thing to work i'm
not entirely sure why it's not working
here but let's go ahead and see what
working with could not find executable
math test uh why not okay so it's kind
of weird it's saying it can't find the
executable but when we go to actually
run them it runs fine right says not run
it saying that before no it passed
before
maybe we need to rebuild everything
let's go ahead and uh just rebuild this
project so we're going to go up to build
or rebuild all should be pretty quick
there we go now let's try this out again
yeah much better we just needed to
rebuild so as expected math test one
passed second one failed as it was
supposed to uh just based on our
goofy little simple condition but yeah
there's a really simple example of just
getting it going uh right there on
visual studio and uh let me know if you
can get this to work this is supposed to
work maybe if i
reopen the project or something it would
work fine not entirely sure why it's not
but uh there you go so there's some
really basic stuff about c-test this
video is extremely drawn out it covers
all kinds of little side cases so uh
yeah i just recommend doing a little bit
of reading if you want a simplified
version but if you get really stuck and
just get don't understand a lot of this
coding stuff that's kind of what i'm
doing more here all right well see the
next one where we're going to cover c
dash which is basically where you upload
these test results to a dashboard and
have that all configured in cmake to
work automatically and also it'll cover
doing things like nightly builds maybe
automatically we'll see all right see
you next time peace
[Music]
you